here we got a guy right here we got
captain Lou albano son right here coming
into us with this great heat wave
incorporated out there twin when did you
make that video they doin this in Corona
times they don't give a [ __ ] dude where
we started Corona dude and I hope that
make a new strand bro me too you know we
need a string that people can have and
still go out and party and work that's
what you're talkin about
um lifted trucks listen I like lifted
trucks I had a lifted truck just a year
ago here's thing about little guys but
they're talking high rider or low rider
you might thing about lifted trucks
though there's nothing worse than shows
that you have a little [ __ ] when you put
you know when they get lifted trucks let
me put the fake balls on the Mac I hate
that [ __ ] really I can't stand it the
nuts are just dangling you're in traffic
just there dangling and lowriders don't
make sense there's anything more Mexican
than a lowrider truck mm-hmm is very
distinctively Latino let you know
strictly yeah
I think it's dope i like it but ok well
that lifted - hitter on that left this
dude on the left
you getting [ __ ] on the right you
getting homies yeah well I don't know
dude they got a lot of [ __ ] die-hard
Latin [ __ ] out there dawg you know
I'm talking about some real [ __ ] dog
that are [ __ ] yeah they'll suck on
your frijoles bro if you have that
[ __ ] a lowrider no ladder home mirror
the magazine lowrider used to have the
baddest [ __ ] yeah on these lowrider
okay so that's what you're saying right
now then you know that's not dude you
get them little [ __ ] 20-inch [ __ ]
hitter bunnies that jump in those trucks
those lifted monster trucks and it's low
so a big girl can even get in the back
if it's a low rider you get your fat ass
no it's not oh you gotta have a lean
Jean you know a lean Janet to climb up
into that lifted truck see a big girl
try to get that lifted thing it's your
wobble off yeah I do know big [ __ ]
allowed catch a 38 to the arm bro she'll
catch it one of those big tires will
roll right over yeah but you gotta have
that Serena Williams [ __ ] backside
jump up in that [ __ ] truck yeah bad
[ __ ] only really oh I think that's a
good look the lower truck you can have
more women can get into the lower truck
and short homies
yeah it's accessible oh yeah and that's
definitely I mean it's five for Nation
bro when you're Mexican I'm I'm more of
a lift a truck guy myself but mitt
lifted truck you can go out there you
can park you can fish off of the back
you can hide stuff from people that are
short now here's one thing about a
lifted truck though they don't grow that
fast I'll lift a truck will top out
sometimes at 60 miles an hour you'd be
surprised then boys put on the
supercharger they put on different
pulleys cane and air filter that thing
gets moving my brother-in-law do yanti
lifts everything I mean he's lifted
everything they've ever owned dude I
mean they have a coffee pot in its own
[ __ ] sevens yeah so I think in my
side of the tracks dude I'm still on the
lifted side but I could be tempted oh I
believe I do believe the shorter that
lower vehicle is a better way to catch a
chicas yes I'm lifted on the female
humans yeah I feel you well they say
that 75% said lifted trucks okay so we
have 25 percent Latino following yeah
viva la revolución you know what I'm
saying yeah that lowrider magazine
though bring up some of those covers
Nick they're the baddest [ __ ]
mamacita's on there was a kid I get oh
yeah
off in Tatas bro the mom Mexican teats
on us boobies nothing but oh my god
oh my god you know what I'm saying
PETA gorilla was on the cover of one oh
you ain't ready for that you don't know
by the headlight you know [ __ ] hot
that headlamp is to put your arm right
dog you know nothing about Vita in that
perfect
Oh cheekers look at these papa look at
these both sides they let you feel me
tits you feel me Danny I'm [ __ ]
Mexican it hard dude I'll [ __ ] pull
my [ __ ] cortisone out and beat
someone over the head with it do don't
give a [ __ ] huh
you know what I'm saying dude I'll
[ __ ] sneak across the border and sneak
back across [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] did I plant a garden but I don't
give a damn dawg [ __ ] dude I'll
Drive out the Alamo and shoot into that
[ __ ] right yep and stay at a [ __ ]
Days Inn for 11 months
dude 13 of my friends all work at the
same place Wow
poor papa dude you look like the gayest
president of a biker gang called the
fondles
[Laughter]
which made biker jackets got the fondles
be sick we've fallen off the [ __ ]
wagon here yeah is that it Nick I don't
know what we're doing anymore
that's it
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]